OpenAI里90%的人都在用Codex，不是90%的工程师，是整个公司90%的人。
对，你前几天发的那条推文说，你想把Codex做成有史以来最好的桌面应用。
对，Codex的质量标准必须定得极高，高到让人打开这个应用去做下一件事时，毫不犹豫，它自然就成了你的首选，就像大家现在习惯打开浏览器标签页一样。
确实，我知道你们不断创下使用纪录的数字。
我不知道，走着瞧吧。看起来很多人确实喜欢这个应用。
你觉得为什么AI和最前沿的模型就是不太擅长设计？
我觉得设计更难评判，因为人的品味是反馈机制的一部分，这用现有技术还很难触及。
那么，现在的产品团队和几年前相比，形态上有什么变化？
OpenAI的每个人都很主动，有很多好点子，所以每个人都在搞各种东西。不是说大家的角色根本不同或者各干各的，而是反过来了。
实现已经不再是成本高的部分了，敢说，品味才是。
你感觉会不会有一种融合趋势，每个人都能做所有事，那就是未来，还是说我们依然会主要分工？
我确实有些担心。我听说很多公司说，我们要取消产品角色，每个人都会成为创造者，然后结果就是……
今天我们的嘉宾是安德鲁·安伯西诺，OpenAI旗下Codex应用的产品与工程负责人。Codex正迅速成为人们构建产品以及处理非产品工作（比如整理电脑文件）的首选应用，
起草文档、进行数据分析、阅读邮件，以及更多事情。如果你坚持听到本集结尾，我们其实有一段录音停止后的片段，当时房间里的制作人开始谈论
他如何在剪辑工作中使用Codex。自今年一月以来，Codex的使用量增长了6倍。目前他们每周活跃用户超过500万。我怀疑这个数字很快会过时。在OpenAI内部，
几乎100%的员工每周使用Codex。而且不仅是工程师。安德鲁是一位由设计师转型为工程师，再转型为产品经理的人，他正在构建的应用正被越来越多的人用来构建
他们自己的产品。在我们开始之前，别忘了查看lenny's productpass.com，可以免费一年获取全球最热门、制作最精良的AI产品，专为Lenny的新闻订阅者提供。那么，
下面有请安德鲁·安伯西诺。
安德鲁，非常感谢你来到这里。欢迎来到播客。
谢谢邀请，这是难得的面对面播客。我很少做这类事情。我们看看效果如何。
我们拭目以待。
我们会看看人们是否更喜欢这样。在我们准备这次对话时，我问你你最希望人们从这次对话中收获什么，你说那就是AI如何改变产品工作的形态。
你所在的可能是最前沿的AI软件团队之一。所以你对事情的发展方向有非常有趣的视角，对其他团队在一两年或更久之后会处于什么状态也有洞察。那么，产品团队的形态现在与几年前相比，
现在作为领导者构建这些产品最难的事情之一，就是我想很多人已经谈过的，流程的颠倒。那就是任何人都能
构建任何东西，对吧。我确实相信现在从零开始，如果你与这些模型对话，无论是我们的还是其他人的，真的，你能搭建出任何你想要的功能。而且这并不一定是软件的难点，但就像
这真的很酷。我觉得这创造了一个环境，让人们都在创造这些东西，对吧？你给人们无限的令牌。OpenAI的每个人都很有主动性，有很多好想法，所以每个人都在构建一切。而
我觉得，你看看我们长期以来运行的产品流程，它有点相反，对吧？它一直是研究构思，可能有一些原型制作，但你知道甚至
当我们过了瀑布模型之后，它仍然有点像是，实现是昂贵的，所以你要做的是通过文档、研究、原型来预先降低所有实现风险，因为原型
和设计更便宜，这是当时的假设，而这种情况已经改变了，完全改变了。现在，我敢肯定有90个不同的探索，针对这个我们迫切需要做的功能，
我敢肯定有90个不同的小组在并行实现和尝试，对吧？
嗯，
所以我想简短的回答是，这反过来了，不是人们在扮演根本不同的角色，或者专注于不同的事情，甚至技能消失了，或者职位消失了。而是
反过来了，对吧？实现实际上不再是昂贵的部分了。我敢说是品味。嗯，但这是策划过程。就像那90次尝试中，这些有什么好的？我们应该把这些融入其他方面吗？对吧？
我们应该怎么框架化？它应该是另一个功能的一部分吗？对吧？开关里应该有多少段？嗯，你知道所有这些事情。本期节目由我们季度的呈现赞助商WorkOS带来。OpenAI、Anthropic、Cursor、
Vercel、Replit、Sierra、Clay和数百家其他获胜公司有什么共同点？它们都由WorkOS驱动。如果你正在为企业构建产品，你已经感受到了集成单点登录、
SCIM、审计日志和其他大公司所需功能的痛苦。WorkOS把这些交易障碍变成了即插即用的API，并提供了专为B2B SaaS构建的现代开发者平台。实际上，每个我投资的初创公司，
当它们开始向上市场扩张时，最终都会与WorkOS合作。那是因为他们是最好的。无论你是试图获得第一个企业客户的种子期初创公司，还是全球扩张的独角兽，WorkOS都是
最快成为企业就绪并解锁增长的道路。它本质上是企业功能的Stripe。访问works.com开始，或者直接联系他们的Slack，那里有真正的工程师等待回答你的问题。WorkOS允许你
使用令人愉悦的API、全面的文档和流畅的开发者体验更快地构建。今天就去works.com让你的应用企业就绪。品味真是个流行词。我想回到那个话题。关于90个
原型的想法。太有趣了。所以让我确认一下我的理解。在OpenAI有一个想法在流传。人们过去写文档。是的。这是我们要构建的。这是功能。这是
策略。现在你描述的完全合理，人们只是创建一个原型，你是说公司里的人们有类似的想法，现在他们不是写文档，而是创建他们的
小原型，这导致了90种不同的东西，人们可以看看，也许选择一个我们想要走的方向。是这个想法吗？
有很多这样的情况，你知道这不仅仅发生在这里。你看到很多产品负责人说PRD已死，原型当道。我实际上完全不相信这个。我认为现在发生的一件有趣的事情是，
因为实现变得非常便宜，跨越所有媒介。非常诱人直接跳到原型，特别是如果你不是工程师，对吧？特别是如果你从未写过代码，或者从未
感兴趣，或者从未有时间。真的很诱人说PRD已死。让我直接展示我的意思。对吧？但我也注意到，对于工程师来说，写很多文档真的很诱人，
很多不值得读的文档。这不是对写文档的人的不敬。而是如果实现是丰富的，那么选择正确的格式来表达你的观点非常重要。如果那个观点是关于一个模糊领域的产品
澄清，那么可能确实是一份文档。如果你想做的只是把东西放到人们手中尝试，并对交互模式进行压力测试，那就是原型。但我认为现在有趣的是，
选择媒介真的很重要。
有一个术语，一个播客嘉宾分享过，当你提到这个时我会想到，叫做“原始标记”。当设计师、画家或艺术家在画布或艺术品上画出第一个标记时，
那个标记是你开始回应的东西。所以一切都从你做出的第一个标记开始涓涓细流。而我听到你所说的是，有时原型是错误的第一步，因为那样你只是在
回应这个原型，而不是另一个想法或者更大的想法。我很喜欢听这个。所以每个人都像是说，“好吧，算了。不写文档了，不要文档，不要审阅。”你是说它们实际上仍然对特定的用例有用。
特定用例。
>> 是的。我觉得，在以前的世界里，媒介本身包含了大量关于过程位置的信息。所以如果你看到某个东西感觉像生产环境中的应用，那意味着
它在过程后期，假设已经被验证，设计已经审视过，这是正确的商业目标，对吧？而现在这些东西似乎被分开了，原因是因为
在事情被充分验证之前，很难获得资源来构建它，而现在这完全变了，对吧？所以我认为重要的是要开始说，我们可以有原型，我们可以有文档，但
我们是否清楚这到底在做什么？因为，你说得对，你不想过度依赖一个本来是探索性的东西，但现在看起来如此接近生产，以至于“哦，视觉上可以上线了”，
但它实际上并不是正确的模型，不代表研究的方向，或者用户的需求，或者对业务有利的东西，对吧？不是要过分强调品味，但再一次，这就像品味一样，要知道
该做什么工作，如何呈现这些信息，如何达成目标，用什么媒介，正在成为最重要的事情。就是这样。这适用于每个领域。当你说好的品味时，什么是品味？
它是否是你所描述的，决定要投资的东西？还是当你有一个东西时，它是否正确？这是要发布的东西吗？谈谈你认为什么是好品味、好的判断力，具体来说什么是
那具体是什么样的？因为人们听到这个词，就会说，“哦，我有好品味。我明白。”那在实践中是什么样的呢？
>> 是的。嗯，有趣。有一条推文，我太沉迷网络了。有一条推文，我想是昨天Linear产品负责人发的。我可能记错了。抱歉，有些人说人们过分强调品味中的审美部分。
他们用保罗·格雷厄姆的例子，说保罗·格雷厄姆显然有很好的品味，却穿工装短裤，对吧？所以，你知道，我们需要稍微厘清品味的含义。
嗯，这里有很多细微之处。我认为这涉及你提到的所有方面。它包含审美部分，但也包含系统思维。比如，这如何融入
系统？我们要去哪里，这属于什么主题？还有如何呈现。很大程度上是关于更广泛的上下文，当然，品味的某些部分就像这个交互动画
不符合它应该传达的语义，对吧？比如，它过于活泼，没有传达出实际的意义。这非常重要，我可能过于关注这个了。但是，还有，比如，
如果我们可以构建任何东西，那应该是什么样的？目标是什么，我们如何达成？我觉得这才是真正关于品味的问题。
>> 当我听到这些事情时，我总会想，随着AI变得越来越强大，做越来越多的工作，人类的大脑在哪里仍然有价值？感觉品味是其中的一部分。还有一件事
我想的是，AI在实际设计上仍然很差。AI的输出并不好。
>> 是的。
>> 很少出现“就是它，他们做到了”的情况。而且总是，“哦，这是云设计。这是Codex设计。”为什么你认为AI和顶级前沿模型今天在设计上不擅长？
>> 你觉得它们会达到那个水平吗？你觉得我们会到达一个“天哪，我们完了”的地步吗？
>> 是的。我倾向于认为有一些实际原因导致它落后，也有一些更难解决的问题。我不在我们的研究部门，我这么说肯定会被骂。我认为设计比软件更难评分，
而且，创建一个循环来训练模型什么好设计什么坏设计，比检查代码编译、按预期运行要繁琐和费力得多，对吧？因为品味中的人性部分
是你需要的反馈机制的一部分。我还认为，实验室历来投资于让模型擅长那些能加速AI研究的事情，而在编码模型的早期时代，很清楚地表明，模型能写出正确代码会加速研究，
而设计方面却不能这么说。不是说擅长设计
这并不重要，重要的是它没有直接处于那个飞轮中，对吧？嗯，这些是实际原因，你知道，这些都会消失，因为模型会变得很擅长设计。还有一些比较模糊的事情。
那真的会非常棘手。嗯，我脑子里有一个简短的清单。一是关于什么被认为是好设计，存在文化方面的因素。你记得大概是去年，每一个
新上线的网站都只是复制Linear的网站，对吧？Linear的网站设计很棒，品味很好。如果模型能做到那样，我会说‘哇，这真是了不起的进步’，对吧？如果我有一个模型每次输出都是
Linear的网站，那并不是挑战所在。在设计中，新奇性比在软件工程中更重要。软件工程，你几乎希望
它过度依赖已知的模式，对吧？而设计则不同，它需要随机性和新颖性，对吧？还有，对我来说，我花了很多时间在早期的Codex应用上编写代码或监督
代码。即使模型变得擅长设计，在软件设计和正在编写的代码之间仍然存在一个抽象层。比如，这个角落里的东西
应该与下面的这个东西在代码库中共享某些属性和方法，对吧？这比简单地说模型需要成为更好的设计师要复杂一些，尤其是那种不是视觉上的，那是视觉设计，
但它更深层。它关乎抽象。比如，如果明天我们公司进行品牌重塑。浅层的版本是我们必须一个个更新263个组件。深层的版本则是
这两个看起来不同的东西之间的语义，它们都在列表中，具有这种样式，向用户传达这种交互模式。我认为这仍然有点超出
当前技术的能力范围，这个抽象层。所以我认为，在我们经历这个过程中，我们从11月开始使用Codex应用，当时我们并没有全职使用它，现在我们用它做所有事情，这是一段旅程。
但现在我们实际使用它做的事情已经不同了。那么，问题是什么？
>> 我知道这是一个很棒的回答。说到设计和创造力，Codex应用刚推出时，它是一件全新的事物。是啊，以前从来没有人见过。它既不是终端，也不是
IDE，而是一个能写代码的聊天界面，你可以看到代码。
>> 是的。
>> 你说得对，感觉AI很难创造出一种全新的编程范式。而这正是人类大脑目前仍然有价值的地方，那就是创造力，提出新的东西，
而不是重复已有的模式。
>> 是的，我完全同意。让我们为人类大脑鼓掌[笑声]。
>> 目前是这样。在我们准备这次对话时，你说你在听Jenny的一集节目，她是Clock Code和Co-work的设计主管，她有一个观点，认为设计流程已经死了。
没有时间做设计了。事情发展得太快了。
>> 直接开始构建，设计在过程中引导方向。你暗示你对设计流程有不同的看法？
>> 关于这方面的很多内容，我和Jenny的看法可能一致。我不喜欢那种正式的设计流程。我同意她的观点，它已经死了，而且即使在AI出现之前，我确实也不喜欢这种流程。
>> 你能简单描述一下这个流程吗？因为人们会想到设计。我的意思是，几年前我创办一家初创公司时，我们会进行设计招聘，然后出现了一篇有点讽刺的文章，
关于所谓的“案例研究工厂”，那是Midjourney时代的事情，对吧？设计师被教导要重视这个流程，甚至把它置于所有结果之上，对吧？如果某件事
经历了这个流程，那么有两个事实成立。一，它会是好的，流程能保证质量和影响力；二，如果某个东西是好的，如果它经历了那个流程，即使你不喜欢它，也没有人使用它。就像流程包括用户研究、发散和收敛，这是正确的框架。
它总是有点学术化，但我觉得这确实暴露了...
它在某些方面确实有短板，尤其是实施速度上。而且，这个过程本身是建立在实施成本高昂、只能建一次的前提上的。
所以你得先彻底摸清问题和解决方案的整个空间，然后再动手。而且你看，像Figma、Origami这类工具，其实可以加速这个过程——
通过提前把交互原型拉进流程，省去一些摸索。你可以模拟生产环境，结果就出现了一个梗，高管们总是问：
能不能先做个原型，然后期待它直接能用？但这事儿是真真切切的，对吧？它成了设计流程的一部分了。我们把原型制作拉了进来。现在的问题是，
你可以把所有实施都拉进来。但很多假设都错位了，比如你看到一个精雕细琢的原型，看起来能直接上线，公司里很多人都看到后
就问能不能现在发布，但实际上我们还在早期的设计探索阶段，没人明说。这就是我们现在的情况，就像在搞多人
探索一样。90个人都会觉得这想法很成熟，看起来很漂亮，但其实不是，这本质上还是设计过程。把设计过程和媒介绑定，这才是可怕
的地方。设计师现在有更多工具来做这件事，对吧？你可以把东西放进当前产品里，然后做A/B测试，或者直接当原型用。很多公司现在都有这种“迷你版”
产品的想法，比如“迷你Cursor”。你在推特上见过，“我们有迷你Codex”对吧？就是一个大幅简化的代码库，模拟了生产应用的所有交互，因此
用vibe coding更新起来快多了。因为你可以说，如果侧边栏这样弄会怎样？或者如果疼痛点在这里加个群聊呢？如果X、Y、Z呢？这就是设计过程中的一个超强工具。所以说
“设计已死”这个说法，我觉得既对也不对。就是说，如果你死守着旧工具、旧规范，还有那些日常流程的细枝末节，那你确实没戏，日子不好过。
但如果把整个流程或者流程框架完全扔掉，比如“我们现在在流程的这个阶段”这种概念，那比以往任何时候都重要。这真的很有趣，因为
你背景很全，大家看你LinkedIn，会发现你做过工程师、设计师、产品经理、创始人。现在你负责桌面应用，我觉得设计可能不在你管辖范围内？是这样吗？是有
独立的设计团队，还是他们归你管？
>> 看情况，每周都不一样。
>> 好吧，明白了。
>> 我们合作很紧密，相信大家坐在一起，融入彼此。在汇报关系上，我不——
>> 他们每周都换？那在Codex上，设计流程是什么样的？
>> 是啊，关于角色崩塌、存在性角色崩塌写了很多文章。说角色都没了，但我们没看到这种情况。我们确实在Codex团队看到了更多角色融合，比公司其他部门
>> 和经济领域都多。我觉得一部分原因是这是给工程师用的技术产品，所以我们的设计师会说工程师的语言，产品经理也懂技术语言，还能写代码。Alexander有计算机科学硕士学位，
>> 而我没有。所以我们看到了很多角色融合，我想，描述我们如何合作的一种方式是，
>> 角色之间的重叠比以前多多了。每个人不再被设计在哪里结束、工程从哪里开始这种界限所定义，而是更多由他们工作的中心点来定义，对吧？所以
>> 比如，你统计一下我们设计团队每个人做的事情，会有很多写代码的，也有很多产品工作，但平均下来，他们的点是在那边的，对吧？如果你
>> 画个图，这也反映了流程本身。尤其是因为Codex应用的整个开发都受到了“吃狗粮”循环的影响。我们所有人都渴望
>> 尽可能多地在应用里完成工作，即使它不是最佳工具，这样它才能变得更好。所以很多设计工作都是我们通过使用应用来做的，然后说“这里有什么问题？”这是我们常做的事情。
我们常常不去改进流程，以便让产品变得更好，这让人非常不舒服，但你知道，每周都在发生变化。我特别喜欢这一点，就像——
你是什么？你的角色取决于你把时间花在什么事情上。如果你的大部分工作是产品经理的工作，那么，好吧，你现在就是产品经理。
没错。
如果是工程，那你现在就是工程师。
我觉得OpenAI是不是第一家称员工为“技术成员”的公司？
不，我觉得这可能是从施乐开始的。我实习的第一家公司叫Up There，他们也这么做。
这种称呼早就有了，但现在更常见了。你知道，这在以研究为重点的公司里算是一种传统。
对，明白了。所以它是从研究领域出来的，但我感觉这正预示了未来的方向。这个想法就是我们都叫技术成员，你的职能不是固定的。
你不是被归入产品、工程或设计那一类。你觉得我们长期都会走向这个方向吗？你觉得职能还会继续存在吗？比如仍然有产品经理的技能、工程师的技能和设计的技能。
是的。
人们会说“我是设计师”，还是你觉得会像有些人说的“建造者”那样，会出现一个融合，每个人都身兼数职，这就是未来？还是说我们仍然会大部分按职能划分？
有些事情我确实感到担忧。我觉得有些公司喜欢非常极端地追随大家说的趋势。我认为部分……
关于消除角色概念的危险在于，它可能会危险地消除这样的观念，即有些事情是专业领域，有着已知的最佳实践，对吧？我听过很多公司说，我们要取消产品角色，我觉得这其实是个糟糕的主意。
然后每个人都只是个建设者。结果就是，他们不重视产品这个学科积累下来的整套专业知识和真实的最佳实践。
那些经过尝试和失败的真实过程就被抛弃了，因为人们觉得“哦，我会写点代码，对吧？”那可不是什么好状态。我觉得像“这不是你的职责范围”这样的边界，我很欢迎它们消失，但这里有一个平衡点。
不是每个人都能做所有的事情，无论是从广度还是深度上，对吧？这就是为什么经理不会消失。
不是每个人都能做所有事情，而且每个学科都有其技能成分，我觉得很多工程师都容易忽视这一点，他们觉得工程就是写代码，其他角色只是人们在瞎搞。
其实不是这样的，对吧？就像你会用Excel，但你不一定能进财务团队工作，对吧？就是这样的事情。
>> 是啊，我想还有一点是，你真的想做这份工作吗？我想……
>> 我觉得现在更多的其实是这样：换角色更容易了，学习最佳实践更容易了，你的角色效能不再与使用具体工具的能力紧密绑定，对吧？更关键的是你能否进入这种心态，学会哪些有效哪些无效，然后专注其中，对吧？
就像我一直觉得自己不该当软件工程师，因为我不关心汇编语言或者背诵TypeScript语法，你知道吗？
这些角色中总有一部分是那种“守门员”性质的东西，就像“擅长这个角色就是擅长这个工具”。我觉得这种东西正在开始瓦解。
我就是觉得人们把这些都夸张化了。
>> 你的Codex团队看起来是什么样的？有多少工程师、设计师、产品经理？团队目前的构成是怎样的？
>> 每次有人问我Codex团队有多少人，你还记得我的回答吗？对，我说大约在10到几千人之间。我的意思是，这是个假答案，但它又很真实，因为我们确实……
这可以说是大家在这里工作的最终成果。
所有投入在模型研究上的东西，所有关于模型如何擅长编码和浏览器使用的知识，所有关于模型个性的设计，以及所有围绕前端的产品工作，
基础设施，所有用户相关的东西，全都融入了这个产品。但同时，我们并没有每天接受成千上万人的随机PR。所以我们有一个由十来位工程师组成的团队，
设计方面大概一半的人数。有几个产品人员，虽然产品角色更像是他自己的防守策略。我认为在Codex团队或桌面端团队中，大家都有一个共同点，就是主动性和品味。很多前创始人，或者在大公司里做过类似创始人工作的人，
在OpenAI有很多非常有品味的人。我们让团队规模变得很大，所以没有那种情况——
嘿，没有管理层，但团队规模相当大，主要是个人贡献者，我觉得这是好事。
你用了“区域防守”这个术语来形容产品工作，我觉得很有意思。这似乎也映射了设计上的转变，就像你在那里管理和协调一样。能多谈谈这看起来是什么样的吗？区域防守
对于一个产品人员来说是什么样的？
是的，我和Alexander关于这个类比聊了很多。这个类比是说，如果两个产品人员合作得太紧密，那通常不是一个好信号。而你作为产品人员，
你想要做这种“力导”式的活动，你会思考：哪里有空白？尤其是在这个新世界里，策展、引导和校准变得很重要，你会看到，
有大量的混乱发生，人们到处抛点子。自上而下、长达一年的规划根本行不通。所以现在我们需要有品味的人从最初的概念来引导产品，
这意味着你基本上需要有全面的覆盖。所以你会分散开来，说：“好吧，谁最擅长什么？让我们之间留出空间，这样我们就能全面覆盖。”这就是我的方式。
就这样。然后你填补空白，你会说：'看，我们想雇佣具有产品思维的工程师。我们不希望的是，你知道，我们有一堆人写了一大堆代码，
却需要整个团队来审查以确保产品一致性，对吧？我们希望每个人都具备这些技能，但我认为人们深入钻研的方向必须改变，对吧？'
>> 这绝对是我和像你这样的人交谈时反复注意到的一条线索——现在最有价值的人，最能创造价值的人之一，是那种能带着品味把想法从构思到完成的人，
知道什么才是好的。就像一直保持着这种追求卓越的执着，这种高主动性、高品味的人。正如你描述的，这是不是就是你在考虑'我们在招谁'
谁能在新世界表现出色'时的思路？
>> 是的，我认为这是现在的核心。这也反映了我如何看待个人贡献者与管理层的关系，那就是管理层不会消失。并不是每个人都变成个人贡献者，但每个人现在都是两者兼顾，
对吧？如果你是个人贡献者，你不是一个字符一个字符地敲代码，对吧？你是在管理某种东西——你在管理代理，你在管理，你知道，你在管理工作，这些工作汇聚在一起完成某件事。
如果你是团队经理，你做的是同样的事情，只是粒度不同，对吧。我通常寻找的，显然是对专业的掌控，但还有品味，比如说'嘿，你将拥有无限量的令牌，
我不希望我们做出来的东西是垃圾，你需要能够辨别什么是信号，什么是噪音，在一个无限内容的的世界里。'
>> 提到规划，在事物发展如此快的速度下，制定路线图变得非常困难。是的，
>> 我想尤其是在我们的领域。
>> 呃
>> 人们一直因为这个对我很恼火。没错。
>> 因为事情一直在更新，东西一直在变，对吧？你们团队是怎么规划的？你们会提前想多远，计划长什么样？是电子表格吗？还是
MD文件？计划到底是个什么产物？嗯，我觉得我们在这方面没什么革命性的做法。我们对于规划并不那么巧妙。我觉得基本要点是，时间越近的事情，细节就要越具体。
而且不是说我们不做九个月的规划，而是那个规划必须保持非常模糊，因为你现在在九个月计划里添加的任何精确度都是虚假的精确度。你只会浪费时间。
你当然可以说一些话，对吧？但我们的规划基本上都不是这样的。我觉得研究方面是不同的。我这里不是代表研究部门发言，但在应用方面，当我们做产品的时候，任何你在十一月计划的东西
可能在十二月还是对的，但显然不是实际发生的情况，所以真的很难做规划。我们通常需要知道模型在什么时间线上能做什么。在我上一家公司，我
就看到了这种转变，我们开始用模型来驱动功能，然后产品流程就崩了。基本上不得不变成这样：让我们列出未来一两年
我们想做的所有事情。让我们把所有东西都做成原型，决定哪些现在就可以做，其他的就先放着慢慢成熟，然后每次模型有新的突破，就把那个东西拿出来换一下再试。因为
功能好不好的前提是基于它们够不够聪明，而不是它们的外形。
>> 所以这是一个关于Codex应用的好故事。我非常确信，我们二月份发布的Codex应用，如果是在十一月就准备好的话，绝对会在市场上失败，唯一的区别就是
十一月到二月的模型变化，对吧？我觉得这里面有很多值得思考的，这个产品外形完全一样，但结果可能会完全不同，仅仅取决于
几个月的时机。本期节目由Mercury赞助播出。这是一家与众不同的银行，深受超过30万创业者的喜爱，现在还有Command功能。我作为Mercury的客户已经超过六年了，我从来没有想过要
离开。Mercury基本上是当银行由产品人员而不是银行家打造时会是什么样子。[音乐]他们让发发票、转账、为团队成员设置虚拟卡这些事变得非常容易，我甚至可以说很有趣。
你的银行有API、命令行原生客户端或支持AI的MCP服务器吗？我想没有吧。就在最近，他们推出了Command，一个直接内置于Mercury中的对话界面，充当你的财务助手。
我一直在用Command来转账、查看我在哪些类别上花钱最多、分析现金流，而就在今天，我用它查了过去一年从某个特定赞助商那里赚了多少钱。
我就问了一句：“过去一年我从X那里赚了多少？”10秒后，答案就出来了。这真是太酷了。访问mercury.com了解更多信息，几分钟内即可在线申请。
Mercury是一家金融科技公司，不是联邦存款保险公司承保的银行。银行服务由Choice Financial Group和Column National Association（FDIC成员）提供。这期播客的主题之一就是：去构建那些目前还不完美但会在模型改进后变得可用的东西。还有另一条主线是雄心：要对你着手的事情抱有更大的雄心。那么，这是不是你做事的一种方式，先搭建一堆可能现在还不行的东西，然后等着模型跟上？
你会有这种思路吗，就是先搞一堆可能现在还不行的东西，然后等着模型进步？
是的，我觉得我们有很多这样的经历。有时候挑战在于你得非常清楚地知道这是设计过程中的哪个阶段。人们还是有一种惯性思维，觉得‘哦，我写了这段代码’，
所以就应该把它发布出去。但其实不是这样的，这意味着我们现在有了一个可以用于测试未来模型的产物，对吧？嗯，这在我们应用里的内嵌浏览器上就发生过，对吧？
我们当时有个能用的版本。回想Atlas的时候，我们在Atlas里有个代理，那真的很酷。在那之前，我们在ChatGPT里也有过Operator，但那没搞成。想法很酷。
这里面其实有一条线，能把Operator、Atlas、Codex和ChatGPT串起来，它们本质上都是同一个功能，但用不同的智能化程度重新发布，结果就完全不一样了。所以我一直劝
大家不要固执地认为‘这不行，所以是个坏功能’。不是的，可能只是还没准备好。还有一点，尤其是在研究领域，总想着要最雄心勃勃，
说‘好吧，理论上模型最后能做到这样’，但在产品方面就是行不通。比如你回头看看最初的Codex发布，基本上就是叫Codex Web，但交互体验不好。
就是你给模型一个任务，它会去做，然后回来给你一个完成的结果，听起来没那么激进。问题是它任务完成得不太好。比如它写
代码。它曾经很好，但那种形态太超前了。然后云端代码出现了，完全是本地的，不连接到云端。它不假装是智能体，实际上也不是。它就像是要问你问题，它会坐在那里，你不能把整个生活委托给它。
那反而效果更好，因为那就是当时模型的能力水平，对吧？所以我们当时对智能体过于乐观了。
我觉得我经常从这个教训中思考。以前，贝利和市场会告诉你产品的形态和沟通方式，但现在不是这样了，
你可能需要发布这个东西六次才能让它正常工作，而且形态可能完全不变。听到你必须考虑这么多变量来构建产品，真是很有趣。
现在有模型和研究的时间表，以及它有多聪明。人们甚至需要理解你可以在云端构建软件，这就是未来，要让人们为这个新未来做好准备，
然后还要考虑团队能构建什么。我喜欢Codex的例子，因为它回到了雄心的概念。我想听听你是否也有过这样的想法，就是要有更大的野心，因为
这些模型能做的比你想象的还要多，有时对市场来说太激进了，他们还没准备好。但你有没有想过推动你的团队更有野心，因为
只是做一些可能在过去看起来疯狂困难的事情，现在容易多了。
是的，这是一个核心挑战。一旦有一个产品或功能存在，人们很容易找到一些小毛病，
优化
他们应该这样做，推特上的人也喜欢提醒我们这一点，我感谢他们。人们应该关注现有功能，让它们更可靠更好。但这也是为什么我们
有自下而上探索的文化，因为有时就像Codex应用出现并某种程度上颠覆了ChatGPT一样，对吧？这个东西将来也会被未来的努力颠覆，这是设计的一部分。
就像你不能总是一个团队同时擅长颠覆性创新和维护产品质量。有人设计了一个流程，让两者兼得。稍微拉远一点看，如果你想想
我们一直在经历的AI影响我们构建产品的进程，从我们过去手工编写所有代码，像是精心制作的人为代码，到现在AI编写我们100%的代码，这真是太疯狂了
到现在你说，现在编程就是引导AI，当你想到我的代码有多少是AI写的，几乎就像我需要引导它多少次才能朝正确方向走
这是AI版本的编程。现在有了代理、循环等等这些东西，你看到的最新前沿是什么样的人们构建方式？是循环吗？还是其他什么，比如最前卫的AI团队
他们现在的运作方式有哪些人们可能不知道的？
是的，循环都是上周的事了。我们讨论过这个。你知道，一个大的问题总是，产品有多少是AI写的？这个问题很难回答，因为如果你用老标准来衡量
去年，我们产品里100%的代码都是AI写的。所以问题就变成了，这些代码是在监督下写的，还是无监督的，对吧？这完全是两码事。
我很欢迎这种目标的变化，因为这意味着我们的产品在进步。我们在自主开发软件方面做了很多探索，也做了很多工具链上的工作。
我们做了很多不同的尝试。比如，如果模型在你睡觉的时候帮你清理代码库，做做垃圾回收，那会怎么样？有一个问题是所有模型都有的，就是它们通常会增加代码的复杂性。
如果所有公司的研究人员都在听，请让模型更擅长删除代码。但你知道，当你试图完全自主运行开发流程时，这就会成为一个问题。这既涉及人的方面，也涉及代码库本身。
比如说，功能请求。怎么教模型去决定哪些功能该做，哪些该忽略，哪些需要整合起来重新调整？怎么教模型去构建正确的抽象层？
所有这些东西都在进步。但我觉得，我们还没到那种可以设定一个循环，比如“改进应用”，然后让它听Twitter、听Slack、听邮件，就能自动改善应用的程度。我们还没到那一步。
但我们正在努力实现它。
你觉得我们能实现吗？我们能达到那种像‘成长’、‘胜利’的境界吗？
‘斜杠目标’、‘赚钱’，比如‘帮我赚十亿美元’？
赢下市场。
我不知道，兄弟。就像我……（清嗓子）
我不是那种会说‘从不’或‘总是’的人。
就那种话。
好吧。作为产品负责人和引擎负责人，你在工作中是怎么用AI的？
有没有一些用法是大家可能不知道这款应用能做的？
嗯，我觉得我现在的职位算是全世界最好的了。但其中特别有趣的一点是，当初我们在开发原始的Codex应用时，我个人的目标就是让它成为我用来写代码的工具，对吧？我就想，我得把它做得足够好，让我能靠它来构建这个应用本身。而当时的Codex应用就是个开发工具，对吧？我们就这样非常快地形成了一个‘吃自己狗粮’的循环，因为你有
自己的‘吃狗粮’循环，你会想，‘哦，我不能做这件事，我应该修一下，这样我就能做了。’现在我能做更多事了，对吧？嗯，你知道，我们发布了它，然后接下来的挑战是，大家开始拿它做
一些不同形态的事情，对吧？现在我需要扩展它，所以我得招几个人来帮忙。于是我的角色变了，同时应用的角色也需要改变。所以我就想，
‘好吧，我得在这里多做些产品探索。我得找出正确的循环来关注大家在做什么，并引导那些偏离轨道的部分。’所以突然间，这就是我开始用Codex应用的方式了，
对吧？我确实还在写代码。我尝试让自己的使用方式和我们试图解决的问题保持一致，对吧？现在我就想，‘我需要建一个电子表格来建模这个’，‘我需要做一次
内部深度研究，把所有投入到这个研究领域的努力都梳理一遍，为了下一版本。’
大概五月份左右，我们发布了一个或多个版本，把应用内浏览器、计算机使用和产物创建功能引入了Codex应用。我觉得那是我们几乎面向所有人的一次发布，大家都听说过‘氛围编程’这个词。我觉得那是我们第一次精心协调的发布，我当时有个Notion文档，
里面记录了所有要做的事情，我就在想，把自动化去收集拉取请求和Slack频道的更新，然后更新状态追踪器，那段时间我觉得自己处于管理产品发布的尖端。
但现在这已经很常见了。嗯，但当时我觉得自己就像在刀尖上跳舞。
总之，我用Codex应用的方式，基本上就是看我的工作变成了什么样，然后怎么让这个东西能处理我需要做的一切。
嗯，我早上起来，会看到我所在的3000个Slack频道里所有事情的每日简报，哪些需要我关注。我可以回消息说，
‘好，给我五个问题，我来回答，我可以，你知道，就这样做。’
你是怎么设置的？对于别人来说，要怎么设置这个工作流？听起来太棒了。
再说一次，我觉得我们还在很多这方面的探索阶段。现在就像是我在做一个自动化，或者说定时任务，说‘我会浏览我的Slack频道，这些都是我关心的’，
觉得最重要的东西，对吧？所以我还在定义这些，比如这些是要留意的不同类别，这里有一些背景，然后你知道，我会把它设成自动化任务。
然后前几次运行的时候可能需要一些调整。幸运的是，有了这个应用，我不需要去学习怎么编辑指令，我就可以直接说，‘嘿，下次运行的时候，能不能麻烦你关注这个’
或者‘能不能不那么重视这个工作流’，或者‘嘿，发生了这事，但简报里没提，你能确保把它包括进去吗？’这样我就可以一路指导它。它会更新它的方式。
它会通知我之类的，太棒了。但我觉得以后啊，这可能一直是聊天机器人形态的一个核心问题，对吧？就是我知道怎么设置这个，我有时间去设置，因为对我来说这是产品发现的过程。
但如果你不是在OpenAI工作，不是开发这个的，你肯定不想自己去琢磨这些。我们得搞清楚这个形态应该是什么样的。
对，我听到的是，我觉得大家可能没意识到，你的应用其实可以很像OpenClaw那样干活。
对。
大家特别兴奋的是，你只要跟它说说话，让它设置个东西，每天帮我检查这个，然后告诉我情况，这已经开始融入各种产品里了。
这太神奇了。所以用户怎么设置呢？就是在应用里直接说，我想设个自动化做这件事，看看我的Slack，这些是我要做的事情。
是的，太好了。
是的，应用会告诉你，你知道的。
是的，它会帮你设置好。如果它没有Slack连接器，它会问：“我可以添加Slack连接器吗？”是或否？你可以点击“是”。我们至少能做的是，如果你不知道如何在应用里操作，他们可以直接问它，对吧？是的。
在应用里做某事，他们可以直接问它，对吧？是的。
我认为这还不够，但这是我们至少能做的。
是的，一个好例子是我建了一个小应用来过滤垃圾邮件。每封进来的邮件，我是在Codex里建的。嗯，每封进来的邮件，它会看看，然后判断这是不是不请自来的那种。
那些我不想看的冷邮件，它会标记好然后放到别处去。要设置这个，其中一步是你得进到谷歌云控制台，去配置那些乱七八糟的订阅API什么的，还有
触发器。你用过那个界面吗？又烦又慢，对吧？所以我就想，等等，如果我让你来做呢？然后我就说，行，你帮我搞定。它就真的，你描述一下怎么用电脑，
我之前从没亲眼见过它在我电脑上这么操作。它就接管了我的电脑，开始自己在那点来点去。
就像说，管你有没有连接器呢，我就直接开始点了。
对，它自己就能搞定。看着它在那儿忙活，真是挺神奇的。
设计连接器之间的决策边界挺有意思的。什么时候用应用内浏览器，什么时候用你连着的Chrome扩展，什么时候用电脑，这些都是靠感觉摸索出来的。我之前看到一条很棒的
推特帖子，把这三样都描述了一遍，还有各自都是干嘛用的。
嗯。
所以，这个人描述得特别好。
这些个人工作流真的很有意思，因为有些真的能派上用场，有些人你知道的，各种尝试。大家都在搞自己的个人系统。你问这里的每个人他们在做什么，答案肯定都不一样，
但后来会浮现出一些共同的模式，我们就觉得，这个应该成为应用里的一等公民功能。我们应该把大家都喜欢设置的这个东西，直接让它开箱即用。
我觉得记忆功能大概就是这个样子，我们有好多用户，其他公司也有不少人说，我搭了个Obsidian库或者Notion空间，然后告诉它怎么建立我的记忆宫殿，
怎么放东西。但我觉得，不一定非得这样。应该有个记忆功能直接帮你做了，对吧，那才是通用的做法。所以这个是其中之一，但还有其他一些
这些就像是你的工作流程，有些东西确实应该设置好，但我觉得我们一直在权衡什么对个人来说有效，什么应该进入产品，而什么只是你完成工作的方式。
什么应该成为基本功能，什么不应该。
对，这就是你之前提到的品味和判断力。说到这些，我想稍微谈谈浏览器使用这部分，因为我觉得人们还没有意识到它有多强大，以及它可能被用来做什么。
这让我想起来，不知道你看没看过丹·希珀上播客的那期，他有个预测，说我们以后会开始用Codex来运营我们的SaaS应用。
对。
所以，不是打开Chrome，
我知道他每天都会在Slack上催我，要这要那的。你觉得我们是不是就这样了，就在Codex应用里工作，用Notion、Linear还有Salesforce，然后让你的智能体在旁边帮你？还是说
你觉得这是另一种方向？
是啊，真的很有意思。因为我们之前确实有过几次浏览器形态的尝试，对吧？比如Operator、Tragic那种智能体模式，还有Atlas，现在桌面应用里又有了内置浏览器。
我们还能安装Chrome扩展，让应用跟Chrome连接起来。我们试过很多形态，也学到了很多东西。中间有很多因素，有很多很无聊的因素。
比如，我们最初发布的应用是个Electron应用，内置浏览器能做的那些事，其实挺别扭的。所以内置浏览器本来是给开发用的，是为了
在你开发的时候测试前端。我们当时就说，这玩意儿除了这个没别的用，因为它就是个开发工具，对吧？然后我们换到了我们的猫头鹰技术栈，这个技术栈曾经驱动过Atlas浏览器，现在
你知道，多标签页，而且我们有企业级安全，这样你就能登录所有网站，如果你，呃，你知道，我们一直在迭代这个。我觉得难的一直是，这个浏览器的形态应该是什么样的。这
是不是只给智能体用的？就是说，你有Chrome，你打开Chrome，你在Chrome里做你的事，如果你问桌面应用，它就会打开这个它能快速控制的浏览器，没有
Playwright那种延迟，但是，你知道，或者我们是想说这个应用是万能的，我们想让你把它当浏览器用，而那些有很多权衡，并不是那种，你知道，走得很顺的路，对吧？就像大多数浏览器是
顶级浏览器有标签页。嗯，这产生了很多无聊但繁琐的问题，比如键盘快捷键，对吧？我们是打算把键位映射到VS Code，还是Chrome，还是我们自己的东西，还是Linear？
或者，你知道，我们希望有一些肌肉记忆能延续，但所有这些都有不同产品形态的子集。我们该怎么办？这正好凸显了这个应用多么具有挑战性。
你得让它既能服务于从未构建过任何东西的人，
从比较基础的用户，到像Peter这样的高级用户。
Open Claw想用这个写代码。
我我不太相信能让Peter用这个应用。我想他可能是最后一个坚守终端的人。好吧。
但我会继续尝试。
好，让我退一步，谈谈大局，你把这一切带向何方。Codex的愿景是什么？它会走向哪里？会是什么样子？你知道，我不
知道，一两年，还是十年。
我们当初有Codex的命令行版本，对吧？然后我们决定构建这个应用。而且，你知道，我们当初对应用有点不确定，但嗯，但我们对它能成为什么很有信心，先是一个开发者工具，对吧？那
是的。
而且它不会是IDE，而是一个恰到好处的界面，有点像聊天机器人，但又不止于此，你可以看到代码，但我们不会让你直接编辑代码。
去年一月和二月，OpenAI发生了一件很有意思的事，当时我们还没正式发布Codex应用，但已经开始内部使用了。我们发现，我们在工程和研究工作流程上逐渐找到了非常清晰的产品市场契合点。
他们非常兴奋，非常喜欢。我们觉得，只要先把质量提上去，然后再发布给全世界就行了。我们确信这会成为一件大事。
但后来，我们在公司内部启动了其他几个工作流程，说，嘿，这个Codex项目在编码代理方面有点意思，我们有来自市场、公关、财务、法务，基本上每个部门的人，都在用这个Codex应用。
尽管这个应用对这些用户并不友好，它总想展示代码，总想请求批准运行RG之类的操作，它做的这些事完全不适合他们。
所以我们为什么不把我们的其他界面也加上Codex呢？比如，把它加到ChatGPT的桌面应用里，加到Atlas浏览器里。然后基本上就是把Codex的经验推广到一个更通用的知识工作工具上。
这些尝试进行了一段时间，然后遇到了最烦人的问题：没有人愿意离开Codex应用，去用那些据说是为其他用户设计的应用。
我想，这其中的教训是，开发者工具和通用知识工作工具之间，有很多细微差别，不是非此即彼的。我们非常坚信这一点。
就像我们常说的，你的角色现在是什么，就是什么。在产品端也是如此。做Excel工作的人不想看到git仓库信息，我们知道这一点。
但我们也知道，从他们做的事情中，我们能看出很多关于他们工作的类型，我们可以从简单开始，然后根据需要把产品做得复杂。这不意味着我们不需要模式。
你可能需要一些模式来组织你的东西，让你明白进入体验的方式。但我们真的坚信，我们在这里构建的是正确的。
它可能会采取一些真正深入垂直领域的形式，对吧？我们与财务团队、科研团队和法律团队深度合作。我们说，如果我们能构建正确的可扩展性
基础组件和正确的通用模型，那你就能用它做任何事。然后我们的挑战就是如何将它推广开来。但这又回到了我们最好的桌面应用
应该是什么样的？所以，Codex是开发工具，ChatGPT是聊天工具，那未来会怎样？这是我们思考的方向。
你说的这点很有意思：Codex应用做得太好了，让大家都知道了它的存在，而且它好用、好玩，所以大家开始都用Codex而不是ChatGPT应用。因此
很明显，方向就是把它们结合起来，避免制造混淆。我知道大家一直在讨论把它们合并在一起的这个想法。
有人称它为超级应用，我真希望他们没说这话，因为现在我得每天听人提超级应用。不过我们会挺过去的。很好。
好的。但这是不是那种——我们不叫它超级应用——而是说人们去一个地方就能做所有事情。这是大致思路还是说待定？
是的。我觉得我们看到的是，它就像一个完美的基地。它是一个跟踪所有你需要在不同平台上完成的事情的好地方。有些事情你可以在应用里做，有些事情
应用会打开其他应用去完成，对吧？应用可以连接Excel，所以它的内部有电子表格编辑器。但对于那些在OpenAI做财务建模、要筹集数十亿美元的人来说，这够用吗？
可能不够。所以应用会直接与你桌面上的Microsoft Excel插件交互。当任务完成后，你就可以关闭Excel了。所以这不只是说，我们在屏幕上画个矩形，
所有事情都得在那个矩形里发生。而是这个东西应该成为你的工作中心，你从那里开始工作，结束工作，自动化工作，它用你需要的任何工具。对吧？我们有一个很棒的故事，我们在这个房间里拍摄了一些用于Codex应用最初发布时的视频，
然后我们内部的DX摄像师Brent负责剪辑这些视频。他用Codex剪辑了所有视频，这是早期
“哇，人们用这个东西做什么？”的例子，对吧？他决定用Codex的原因很有趣。他一开始只是好奇Codex能不能剪辑视频。而Codex并不是一个视频
它本身不是编辑器，对吧？它没有任何那种界面，但它能理解他使用的是Premiere Pro。它可以通过编辑支撑Premiere Pro屏幕显示的那些文件来做一些编辑，但它不能
做所有事。所以自然地，Codex就给自己构建了一个扩展，可以安装到Premiere Pro里，然后它就可以跟那个扩展对话，说：‘嘿，Premiere Pro扩展，你能帮我改一下Premiere Pro应用里的这个标记吗？’
当我们看到这种情况发生时，那真是相当疯狂。嗯，这是一个很好的模式，对吧？这些专业工具各有所长，所以我们试图用Codex和
现在用ChatGPT同时做两件事：一是我们如何与你已经使用的这些工具无缝互动，比如我们不需要为你构建一个更好的视频编辑器，对吧？但Codex和ChatGPT可以使用那个视频编辑器，对吧？它可以
进行交互，可以把手头的事情交给它，对吧？所以那怎么做呢？通常是通过连接器、计算机使用，或者在这种情况下甚至扩展。然后还有Dan Shepard的做法，那就是，嘿，我有
这些网页应用，你可以点击使用，但我想在Codex里打开它们，然后让Codex用它们做额外的事情，对吧？所以这就是两种几乎互为镜像的模式，我们同时在这两方面做了
很多工作。
>> 这个Premiere的故事对我来说很有趣，因为这是另一个例子，说明对于这些AI工作要更有雄心。你可能不知道，也许它们能做这件事。几乎就是去试试看，看看它能不能解决。
我要把我们带到播客的一个常设环节，我称之为失败角落。那么问题来了，人们看到像你这样的人，看起来一帆风顺，不断成长。一切都在赢。Codex表现那么好。这个疯狂的
职业生涯，一切都直线上升。人们可能看不到那些事情不顺利、你推出的东西失败了的时刻。所以这些故事对人们来说真的很重要，要让他们知道并非总是
一直赢。你有没有一个在职业生涯中失败的经历，教会了你非常重要的事情？听你这么说我有点觉得有趣，这也许是我第一次没有
感觉自己是个失败者。我的意思是，我当了好长时间创业公司创始人。最后基本上是把公司卖掉了，对吧？那真是好多年。那段历程非常艰难。是监管很严格的领域。整个过程感觉
像是一直在失败。然后我去了另一家创业公司，我们试图做AI工具，同样在一个非常封闭和监管严格的行业，那感觉就是一次又一次尝试，却都不成功。所以
对我来说，我其实失败了很多次，你知道，有时候就是时机对了，比如技能、热情和市场时机契合了。我们通过这个项目把我们从Codex应用中学到的东西和
ChatGPT结合起来。这里不知道有多少次微小的失败，我们说‘这应该是这个形状’，然后把它扔到Slack里，结果有2000条消息的讨论串说我们有多蠢。
而且这正是我喜欢OpenAI的地方，人们会直接告诉我们，对吧？当我们内部产品失败时，他们毫不留情。正因为如此，外部产品
一直相当不错，因为它经历了这些循环，就像
>> 2000人觉得这很烂
>> 我失败了大概10到15年才走到这一步，所以我现在每天仍然惊讶于事情进展顺利。我知道，但我还是觉得……
>> 我觉得这对人们来说真的很重要，你可以有很多事情不顺利，然后事情开始变得非常好，只要继续前进，不断学习，我想这就是一个教训。好了，我们
到了非常令人兴奋的快速问答环节。我有五个问题要问你。
>> 太好了，开始吧。嗯，有两三本书是你最常推荐给别人的吗？
>> 你看，我现在是个家长了。我是小孩子的家长，所以我不太确定。有一本叫《咕噜牛》的书，给我的孩子们看的。哦天哪，我们孩子最近对咕噜牛着迷了。
>> 是的。
>> 嗯，我们有个睡前清单，现在就是睡衣、刷牙、书、咕噜牛，还有小毯子。
嗯。
嗯，真不错。
我现在看的其他书也是这种风格。其实《咕噜牛》也不算差，我觉得有些书更一般。
好温馨啊。虽然每本童书都跟生死有关，不是谁吃谁，就是谁杀谁，总有点谋杀之类的阴暗面。
对对，还有毁灭。
还有暴力。
即使对他们来说感觉不到暴力，但字里行间还是有。
这会形成一种情节弧线和紧张感。
嗯。
嗯，好的，选《咕噜牛》不错。
我手头积了一大堆书，我得全部看完。
你孩子还喜欢其他童书吗？
说到这个，我对童书可熟了。我最喜欢的一本是一本很老的书，叫《大橙点》之类的。你可以查查，真的很棒，去买吧。如果你
讨厌业主协会，那就去买。这本书讲的是普拉姆先生，他住在一个所有房子都一样的街上，街道很整洁。有一天，一只鸟把一大罐橙色油漆丢到他房子上，他就说：‘管它呢。’
‘我要大干一场。’于是他去店里买了油漆、吊床、鳄鱼什么的，彻底把房子翻新了。邻居们都炸锅了，你知道的，业主协会、房产价值之类的。
这本书其实不是讲业主协会的，但我本人非常反感业主协会。这书真的很酷。然后邻居们一个一个去跟他谈，喝了他们所谓的柠檬水，但那柠檬水很有说服力，因为一个一个，
他们全都开始翻新自己的房子。比如有个家伙把房子弄成了船的样子。我觉得这本书很好，特别是那些刚买房的新手，应该读一读。
我从这里面听到的是自主权。
对，就是自主权。你可以直接去做事情。
直接去做。太棒了。好，我们继续。最近有没有喜欢看的电影或电视剧？有空的话。
《神奇校车》回归了，在Netflix上，是新的动画版。里面有凯特·麦克金农配音，因为弗瑞丝老师现在成了弗瑞丝教授，她还在，但已经不是主角了，凯特·麦克金农配
主角弗瑞丝老师。我一直挺喜欢《神奇校车》的。
我从来没看过。
我个人没时间看电影，所以我就连续看Netflix的剧。你知道那种做法，就是
哦，我坐不住看整部电影，然后看几集剧，保持，
我确实这么做了。这玩意儿有点让人上瘾。
你最近发现的最喜欢的产品是什么？
什么是个糟糕的答案？我感觉我每天都在发现我们的产品。太棒了。
真是这样。
我觉得Linear做得很好。在Linear之前，Linear一直是我最喜欢的软件产品。
你们就是用这个来规划工作的吗？
嗯，理论上是的。
你有没有最喜欢的人生格言，在工作或生活中常常会想起的？我想问每个和我一起工作的人这个问题，因为我觉得我不是一个爱用格言的人，但别人常告诉我我常说的一些话。
是啊。比如我们在聊这些之前，有很多小点让我印象深刻，我已经把它们融入到这个对话中了。我完全理解你说的。好的，最后一个问题。你做过产品经理、设计师和工程师。哪个
是三者中最难的角色？哪个更难搞？[笑声]
是的。我知道。我觉得它们都非常不同。让一个人觉得困难的事情可能对另一个人来说很容易。关于这个三角关系有很多看法。这个三角关系会怎么发展呢？
比如设计师是不是没用了，或者设计师应该写代码吗？产品经理是不是没用了？工程师呢，我们还需要工程师吗？因为产品经理会写所有代码？或者设计师现在要去做产品经理了？然后所有人都没用了，
所有人都一样，我不知道，似乎有一些融合。出现了一些流动性，我觉得这很新鲜也很棒，尤其是对那些有主动性、想去做
需要做的事情的人来说。同时，像我们说的，有些事情不应该消失，但我认为人们应该找到值得做的事情，然后去想办法做那些事。这是
一个很棒的结束方式。Andrew，非常感谢你的到来。
谢谢。大家再见。非常感谢收听。如果你觉得有价值，可以在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你最喜欢的播客应用上订阅这个节目。另外，请考虑给我们评分或留言评论，这真的能帮助
其他听众找到这个播客。你可以在lennispodcast.com找到所有过去的节目或了解更多信息。下集再见。我喜欢那个关于Premiere里Brent的东西。
是的，
那很酷。我也用过编辑功能。基本上就是
简单的事情，比如，你能把它剪成三段吗，你知道，如果对话中有停顿，第二个和CEX能理解。基本上，我们觉得每个工作都始于这样一个故事，
就是产品不是为此设计的，但它是一个空白的聊天机器人，能写代码。所以什么都能做，但像什么
有哪些有用的事情它能做呢，
对吧？我的意思是，人们只需要对项目有好奇心。他们必须，
你知道，有一个明确的目标，然后把Codex作为一个平台来实现，看看会发生什么，
因为完全没有风险。
对吧？就几个token而已。
几个token。
但当然，如果你在OpenAI工作，这方面的风险就小多了。
是啊，你问过
其中一个人，或者其实很多人，问的是哪些技能重要，然后你也聊到过那种超级厉害的新毕业生，对比
嗯
我不知道你是不是非得守着现有的流程不变。我也不确定该给什么建议，但要说一条的话，就是别死守着你的流程不放。要守住的是
你独一无二能带来的成果
然后去改变你的流程，去尝试新东西。就像
你不断
我最擅长理解Figma的自动布局，比如
对
你在干嘛？
对吧？因为AI也会在这方面变得更强。
你就不断抛出有趣的点子。
保持住。这种自我认知水平，想跟AI一起成功，真是疯了。
确实。
是啊。
这也是为什么我不敢轻易说事情会怎样发展，因为我想着我父母也是思想开放的人，他们也投入事业，但这里行得通的东西，就是不会
对所有人都行得通。这话不太好听，但确实是这样，
你知道，但这里的人都是自我选择的，比如，‘哦，我是那种能琢磨出下一步该干嘛的人’，而大多数人不会成为早期采用者。
而且老是得重新学东西，也挺让人沮丧的。是啊。
你知道，就像‘该死’，
又得学个新东西。
是啊。我讨厌重复。这算是我个人的毛病。也正因为这样，我从来不是最好的媒体人，因为我就是讨厌重复自己说过的话。
完美。
嗯，当创始人真惨，如果你讨厌重复自己的话，因为那你得不断重复讲。
就像个复读机兼主管。
所以对我来说，如果能每天以不同的方式做我的工作，那太棒了。
但那样的话，就不是...
你为你的工作找到了产品市场契合点。
没错，是啊。不，那就是我，我其实没法谈判，因为我说，我不想要别的工作。[笑声] 真了不起，老兄。